So before we go on to the next example, Michael, I wanted to
do a quick quiz, just to make certain you really get what's going
on here. The, the sort of power of looking, using Bayesian learning. The,
the main insight, I think, I, I want to drive home here, is something
you said. Which is that, when we were doing regression before, when we
were talking about the perceptrons, we actually had in our head a particular
kind of function, a particular hypothesis class. In here with what been talking
about with Bayesian learning, the answer tto
finding to sum of squared errors was
independent of the hypothesis class and only dependent upon the
key assumptions that we were making, mainly that we had
labeled the data with certain form, and that that data
was generated by a process that took deterministic function and
added some Gaussian noise to it. So, here's the quiz.
Here's your training data. You've got a bunch of Xs
and a bunch of Ds. These are the values that
you have to learn. And I want you to tell
me, which of these three functions over here, these three
hypotheses is the best one under this assumption. Got it?
>> mod? Are we allowed to do that?
>> We are allowed to do that because
>> It's just a function.
>> It's just a function, man.
>> Interesting.
>> It's just a function.
>> So we've got a linea-, a
constant function, a linear function, and we've talked
about those, but we've also got a mod
function. alright, and we've got a uniform prior
over these threes hypotheses.
>> Yup.
>> Okay. Yeah, I think I can do that.
>> Okay. Go.